I just want to say that our young
granddaughter she played my
granddaughter Juliette Lewis here is one
of the great young actresses in this
country yeah and she was young and so
sensitive and she dealt with all our
craziness remember and she dealt with it
so well everybody wish she had it though
everybody they would just hang her
though that Juliette that Juliette that
she's she's got it got it feel that you
had the exact perfect take on that
character you know kind of bored a
little embarrassed that she's in this
family oh so anytime you cut to do
Juliette is this I was listening to jimi
hendrix in my trailer you know I was 15
I think you're an exceptional 15 like
the average thank you while Juliette was
listening to jimi hendrix I would come
over to a trailer I remember one day
trying to impress her and I I I went to
a vintage store and I found this blazer
and I was like I'm gonna impress
Juliette my blazer knock on her door I
think you were having your afternoon nap
which just uh always informed me that
you had a much cooler life on me because
you needed an afternoon nap at fifteen I
know you were doing fun stuff that I
wasn't invited to and I was like hey I
just wanted you know I'm going out
tonight
got my blazer and she's like yeah where
you going home Zach oh no this I'm gonna
this poison concert and she couldn't
have been more unimpressed with that
she's blaring Iggy Pop and Hendrix River
trailer yeah it's at a stadium
I remember do you remember that really
you were like my little brother and
stoned to the bejeezus but what I mean
and then of course cuz I looked up to
her so much off camera and then in the
non and to be able to watch her
incredible incredible leap inspiring the
career in the grounds that she's she's
broken it's just
just I've been constantly in all of you
since that day it's just incredible
[Applause]